bonjour menaçait donc dix cycles
cortèges de manifestants doit s'élancer
dans un instant est celle où c'est sous
le signe de l'amour que le personnel
hospitalier s'est mobilisée aujourd'hui
le but déclaré sa flamme déclaré tout
son amour à l'hôpital public pour le
préserver il demande plus de d'effectifs
plus d'une hausse salariale et vous
pouvez peut-être le voir derrière moi
sur les images de charles poizat seker
brandi en signe d'amour à l'hôpital
public un hôpital qu'il faut préserver
et qu'il faut protéger ils sont
plusieurs centaines à s'être rassemblés
ici devant l'hôpital necker
vous pouvez le voir juste derrière moi
ils vont ils vont s'élancer dans les
rues de paris pour le moment je vous
propose d'écouter quelques à quelques
personnes acquièrent on a pu parler
concernant cette mobilisation
aujourd'hui écouter les au quotidien des
brancards qui restent des heures et des
heures des patients qui reste inquiète à
36 heures chez nous y'a pas
d'hospitalisation donc un manque de son
auprès des patients on peut pas les
nourrir correctement on peut pas aller
soigner correctement sont ici pour of
manifester notre mécontentement la casse
du service public
le manque de moyens le manque de
personnel sur l'hôpital on y va des fois
avec la peur au ventre on sait pas ce
qu'on va en contre en rentrant c'est
malheureux c'est de plus en plus
compliqué malheureusement on n'a pas de
solution non quand on essaye comme on
peut
de gérer parce qu'au bout il ya des
patients il ya des gens donc on est là
mais on est de plus en plus fatigués
c'est de plus en plus compliqué vous
l'avez entendu ils sont mobilisés depuis
des mois ils vont continuer de battre le
pavé ce cortège qui va démarrer d'ici
quelques instants
devant cet hôpital necker il va
s'élancer dans les rues de paris pour se
terminer devant l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière